this is a production of Cornell
University I know you're prepared you've
been at this for a while oh yeah to hear
that you guys have been working on the
flame and stuff for all we're all in
we've been alright so we just started on
that a few months ago and we're seeing
some really cool stuff it seems like the
most stupid thing in the world to go out
and scorch all of the turf but when you
see how dramatically and how rapidly the
turf recovers but you get this
selectivity between certain weeds and
not especially like seedling control you
can be even less aggressive on the flame
get the job done your recovery is even
faster I mean it's a huge thing timing I
think one of the things we're seeing
with Chris's work out at the vineyard
and as soon as you know life gets
somewhere back to normal we would get
you out there to see we did like a early
post flame on crabgrass we saw some
early seedlings coming up out there and
we went out with a very quick burn he
wasn't driving very slow at all and man
did it provide here st. controls season
long I think it's the seen rain Shawn I
think we might be taking out that seed
rain at the top and the grass is just
getting going it's the best time for it
to regrow and your colleague only liked
it on phrase mowing that Juvenal turf
that new tissue coming up that's much
more aggressive than sort of mature
plodding along yeah it actually helped
in long-term it helps your overall
quality of building because it gives the
turf room to grow it gets rid of all the
old stems and sticks and stuff and you
know it's pretty cool it's even telling
prevalent for one season grasses are
stolen if Chris grass is where you just
need to get rid of a line that old stand
material that's right and I think
further it's not just about dead
material but I wonder if this same
dramatic defoliation whether it's phrase
mowing burning final sand clove oil
whatever organic burned
waipuna foaming whatever it is I think
that timing of that defoliation not so
much what kind it is but the timing may
be more critical than actually the way
you do it
but I'm guessing yeah yeah well we're
definitely seeing there are certain we'd
speed so we're looking at all the
different turf types and then we also
have a couple of sites that have just a
smorgasbord of weeds and so we're
looking at how different durations of
flame per unit area and at some point I
want to figure out what we're doing in
BTUs because one one of the issues you
know like prevailing atmospheric
conditions ground moisture all that
could factor in well anyway we're seeing
huge differences in plant response
species response like we're that
threshold or where that cliff will be
between one weed or another if you're
talking a half of a minute one minute
two minutes three minutes whatever
wherever that non-return cliff is from
one species versus another is vastly
different so we're seeing a lot of
species separation what makes it work is
the rapid turf recovery in almost all
cases we're getting acceptable turf
quality back in a week
and I was in the salt and I'm talking
from Black scorched I mean there's
nothing left but ashes in one week later
we've got pretty darn good looking turf
and cool season warm season cool season
well and I'm referencing cool season
right now our warm season work right now
is kind of spring and we're finding out
as with herbicides during green oats not
a good time to come out and burn warm
season turf it probably should have been
done during dormancy when the stuffs
asleep anyway Bert we're gonna burn it
we're gonna if they thought pesticide
odor or drift was a problem wait till we
start burning everything really pissed
about that yeah so I will just introduce
everybody here today thanks everybody
for joining I know zoom kind of updated
here in the last week now we have a
password you know hopefully I got that
out in time for some people to join
but I guess today as we've been talking
about a little earlier you've heard that
dr. Shawn askew from Virginia Tech he's
here today we'll talk about polis and
it's a new pull of products that were
really excited about we've already
talked about burning as a method of weed
control so we I'm sure we'll get more
into that but as always we'll start with
dr. Frank Rossi Frank and give us a
little update where we been the past two
weeks at least in the northeast here and
then we'll get to the conversation yeah
big thanks to Shawn thanks Carl
big thanks to Shawn can you hear me okay
yeah yeah okay big thanks to Shawn for
joining us and of course big shout to my
pal Carl who's put up with me for the
last a couple of months anybody who has
to put up with me on a regular basis
like this is deserves a medal somewhere
and I have to say it's heartwarming I
like to start out with a picture I find
you know blowing around Twitter Twitter
when I'm not watching professor I ask
you devise country songs to the control
of weeds and other things the the real I
have to say widespread return of golf
course superintendents bringing their
families to the golf course and taking
pictures of it being really proud of it
and celebrating and I know this is
particularly warm to Carl's heart
because they're sitting by the side of
the green eating chick-fil-a your
favorite food all right so so let's do a
quick weather I haven't seen you guys in
a couple of weeks so we have caught up a
little bit but you can see you know it
feels really warm and it has been really
warm during the day but it's still
cooling off at night throughout much of
the Northeast even down where Shawn is
probably at the elevation level you're
getting some differences and so you can
see by the by the you know the heat
accumulation we're still a little bit
behind but the heat has really brought
on the growing degree days which then
gives us an indication about broadleaf
weed control we still use this model
from Purdue as a guide of when Esther
and Amin formulations we've talked about
this in the past since we're talking
weeds today but one of the things we are
noticing is that it's getting a bit dry
in many parts of the Northeast now maybe
not so much again down in Virginia tak
down in Blacksburg way but you can see
when you look at precipitation -
potential evapotranspiration you can see
throughout much of the Northeast
especially the northern parts of the
Northeast it's really starting to get a
little bit dry you can see that we're
expecting a further drying whether we're
getting regularly losing around an inch
of water a week now and so it's really
good obviously you're all noticing it
you're grown grass on sand in many cases
that we're striving for really good
drainage obviously now a water
management becomes a significant part
and boy did that switch click quickly
we went from cold 40 degree temperatures
to now well into the upper 80s here in
upstate New York now what's fascinating
about this again if you look at our
weather conditions right you can see
heat stress is defined essentially when
your nighttime temperature and your
nighttime relative humidity some to an
excess of a hundred and fifty right when
you're in excess of 150 between
temperature and relative humidity in the
evening hours a p.m. to 8:00 a.m. that
gives us heat strikes conditions and you
know one day two day three days of those
kinds of things you can see we're
finishing up coming out of some heat
stress that looks like it's going to
dissipate towards the end of the week
but we've got another day of it here
it's worth checking out on the forecast
website how about the soils obviously
the soils are warming dramatically look
at how they're warming west to east this
time and you see this pattern sometimes
based on where the winds and the
weather's come from we had a lot of east
wind the last week so you're going to
see a little bit lower soil temperature
soil temperatures makes us think about
soil pathogens oh boy or pathogen since
we talked about and Steve McDonald
posted a really nice blog on his green
cast blog this Steve McDonald is a must
follow kind of guy if he writes or does
things he's always worth paying
attention
just the value of being observed in and
here is take all patch in higher cut
bentgrass that he doesn't see very often
but this is a picture taken recently
where you see alternative plants growing
inside there right Bank grass at a lawn
height cut
now what about diseases a couple that
you know the conversation is a little
bit more involved than it used to be in
the early season when nothing was
happening because now if you go to our
forecast website you'll see this
historical and predictive modeling of
various disease and pest pressure like
weeds and in sand diseases as well and
so here is the map over the last 30 30
days down in Farmingdale
I usually tracked the Bethpage State
Park where we do a lot of our research
and you can see over the last several
days anthracnose pressures been pretty
high what about the dollar spot pressure
high and looks like it's getting a
little bit higher building throughout
the Northeast obviously this is the kind
of thing you want to keep track of and
your Smith Kearns model as well a little
bit of note from Mike Hadley at the
black course about annual bluegrass we
will already starting to take out some
collars early indications right we're
adults were tough to get they were
spread out a long period of time they
don't use adult decides with with the
absence of durst band now in Bethpage so
they have to rely on larvacide so now
obviously this is beginning to give
indication set you know we've got to get
those larger sides out and here's
Steve's blog post about adult activity
and larval activity all right well the
conversation for today is is around this
particular problem that Piper and Oakley
talked to us many many moons about in
the original turf for golf courses book
the very first one published and it's
still something that has struck we
struggled with as an industry for those
that look on it as a weed today the
conversation is annual bluegrass as a
weed not annual bluegrass and in
maintenance maintenance and if you don't
know sean has a wonderful presentation
he's given it's got to be from a seminar
something Shawn where you've done this
really comprehensive review
of just about everything you know if you
want to know what's going on in annual
bluegrass control just looking through
the slides in this presentation that I
pulled just prompt our conversation
today's show and what a wonderful job
you did here I love how you've done some
of the price comparisons with the
different products right and you know
people forget you know progress
exonerate velocity tenacity all with
post-emergent
activity you you know did a really nice
job of looking under you know this
particular study we looked at a variety
of different annual bluegrass control
programs over a two-year period see you
know I like when people send out data
that's multiple years of time and of
course as we introduce the methods olan
a product developed by SJ kim cornell
alum now in in south korea many years
ago you know we're having this
conversation in 2020 show and i remember
when this thing was going to be labeled
in 2016 and this is your work from the
early teens 2010 I think you sprayed the
first one in 20 2009 yes that you just
showed there was young
Hans work at Penn State
Young is now like national leader for
pork you porker in the USA right I bet
he did that work at Penn State but yeah
it's uh it's been on it's been a long
ride since oh nine and a pretty cool one
except for the fact that like you said
we we've been for ten years
expecting imminent registration and
finally finally it's here fine so let's
start with the questions um it seems to
me that we've had products that can kill
PO an your the problem is we like them
on greens that's where we want it and
when it dies you know the ball doesn't
roll so good and you've also so we're
not gonna get into that because if I let
Carl loose on your study with the ball
deflection we'll get nowhere on this
topic so so let's
just talk about let's start there there
are other post-emergent products what
makes Methos Oland different so the the
thing that that has limited our
application on greens for so long is the
inability to get true selectivity
between bentgrass
and poet so they are products that can
kill power but the the putting green
management the autonomy on the green is
such that we are so sensitive to
environmental stress
we're so sensitive to have root
senescence rapidly and we're always in
this Evan flow trying to read what the
turf is telling us respond to it and
keep it happy and herbicides I don't
think there is a herbicide on the planet
that's gonna help with that you know you
get your salary by managing big grass
stress herbicide doesn't help with that
so poker is the best ever at giving us
that selectivity it's still her design
and we still have things we need to
tiptoe around but it's the best at at
selectivity between polar and bent like
the product is it's got just a lot of
really good things that we would want to
have it's got a very quick environmental
degradation which you would think oh we
don't want that laurent hang around and
kill the poet well the good news is you
can go through five to seven half-lives
of this product and still get polar
pre-emerge if you're using it at their
point six fluid ounce rate that we
recommend in post-emergent
so it's still its rapid degradation but
but huge selectivity between poem bit
and so we can it also gives us the
ability but we don't know the motive
action we've done a lot of work on that
we're not yet there yet but the way it
works it gives us the ability to just
turn that nut a little bit fun and a
little bit further until we slowly
transition out the pole which is we've
had other products of ALS inhibiting
products photosystem inhibitors that you
just can't do that either it's going to
work and if it does it works I mean
right now or if you dial it back a
little bit it just absolutely does not
work you get complete recovery every
time and we've never been able to say
okay well I'm gonna put six apps out and
a in a strategy that's part spring part
fall and just slowly transition the poet
everybody says they want that slow
transition but then they start applying
the product and they're like oh man it's
no not dying well you just hang in there
that that so the downside is in order to
get that slow transition it takes one to
two years and no one everyone goes in
saying I'm cool with that but they get
halfway in saying man I'm not cool with
this it's not happening fast enough but
but that's what we're trying to do and
that product can do it that's I remember
when I was first chatting with what is
the young man's name that was at Penn
State young young yeah yeah I met young
many times when he was first going
around when this was first happening and
one of the things he used to say to me
early on was they were using it in Korea
and he said Frank they just sprayed it
on these warm season grass fairways and
they didn't see they didn't do anything
all they did was just let what was there
sort of fill in and do its thing so let
me ask two questions one is you said it
takes a number of years let's start with
best practices I understand the jargon
is fall program spring program we don't
have to get into the minutiae of rates
I'm sure it's important but let's start
with what are best practices and at the
same time do you need to see can this
happen and let's refine our comments
even further Sean let's talk about
putting greens because what your work
showed too is there's a lot of good
products for fairways tees in rough
there are a lot of good products nobody
pays attention to you made the case for
exonerate there's maybe a better product
yeah there is as well so if you're going
to talk about greens we don't then then
rate becomes easy there is only one rate
it's 0.6 fluid ounce per thousand though
that that's all rate we don't really
have to go so then the question becomes
how many applications I'm am I going to
apply at what frequency and win alright
and if you're applying those
applications in the spring what you're
gaining from that is a very slow like a
stunning of growth and a
very slow reduction of population that
with say three spring applications
you're probably not going to get much
more than ten twenty percent population
reduction with spring programs it's not
that is not your I'm going to renovate
I'm going to kill it all program it's
not going to happen in the spring we're
trying to arrest expansion and set
ourselves up to get it's all about what
are we paying an injury risk too bent or
well what are we paying in risk to the
putting quality is really what it is
because the product is safe on bent
unless we really do something outside of
the herbicide that is stressful that the
herbicide then can then exacerbate then
we might get some vent injury but the
product alone at the rates were using
will not harm meant those the full
application set up the program for the
fall that's right so the spring programs
are getting us and hopefully a little
bit better position to get a little more
bent than we had so that we can go after
the pole in the fall so two applications
is usually all it takes three is is in
most cases going to be complete
renovation of polar if you're doing in
the fall so if you're if you have a
population that's not responding to pork
here very well then what you when I say
turn that nut a little bit tighter what
you can do is you can shift one or two
of those spring applications into the
fall and that's really going to ramp up
product performance or killing polar
which again everyone needs to remember I
know you won't get dead I'm going to
dead but what we're struggling against
with this herbicide and with our
playability is to take the pull out
slowly and so if you put now you could
save some money if you're willing to
take that decline in putting quality
peel and swallow it you could go out
with for fall applications take your
pole out and the following spring what
you're going to be left with is if
you're dealing with a 50 to 70% pole
green what you'll be left with is the
vent grass is going to wake up the pole
is all going to look
you can manage that with colorants but
it's going to start to die and it's
going to start to melt out before the
bit can fill in you're going to end up
dealing with about four weeks of pitted
cutting surfaces something on par with
an aeration event and once you grow that
in you're essentially pure event and a
lot better so that may be a strategy
some people are looking for but most
people are going to go toward a couple
of spring apps and two to three fall
apps or more often maybe up to for
spring apps and up to two all apps it's
just so so with that yeah so there's
lots of ways but one of the things I
think is critical and and you know Carl
and I know this because we study a
little bit the decision making practices
of superintendents and and and the
deliberateness of on some cases and and
the reflexive in other cases right and
and so when is a good time to know if
what you're doing is working right let's
say I did the to fall treatments how do
I know when I gotta turn that nut and
I'm thinking at the same time you know
you you you know develop the late fall
application seed head control
something's happening to pol annua
even in a perennial form in that part of
the year so tell me number one what do
you think's going on with Poe at that
time of year that maybe he's helping
with Methos ole and control as well and
then how do when do I evaluate it can I
evaluate at the summer of next year to
know if what I'm doing is working so
first of all I do think the evaluation
is going to be in year two and so
depending on your scenario and what you
want I think so the way right now the
way the products being marketed and
superintendents go to polar calm and
they enter a direct relationship with a
manufacturer so every so right now all
but five US states have had
registrations of which New York is five
California is not one Florida is not one
Washington and that's the New York
California Washington and I can't read
my writing on the other one anyway so if
it's in New Jersey and Connecticut it's
somehow gonna leak through the Hudson
River you know we don't want to talk
candidly about this and I think there's
gonna be a lot of scrutiny of it so
let's just say you work directly with
the manufacturer you don't have a
salesperson that you generally will deal
with the way you do with your other
products so they are going to get from
you what do you want and they're going
to give to you here's what we recommend
and also one of the things that that
they've implemented is if you did not do
the EP or have not tested the product on
your course before now then they are
requiring that you your maximum purchase
in year one is only four bottles which
is only enough to do some
experimentation on your course if you
say screw that I want to get started now
then you have to sign a waiver ah so but
they're they're strongly encouraging
people to get on-site experience with
the product before they proceed because
of the sensitivity of putting greens and
all they of course of course scenario
you so the question you asked was
alright what are we doing the scenarios
are going to be probably five or six
applications per year and they're going
to be catered predominately in the
spring and less in the fall after you're
done with exactly what that program
implementation is that is the time the
time to the question is this working is
not midstream as that's what that's the
mistakes that we've seen over and over
and all the experimentation people get
midstream and saying I it's not working
oh we all we didn't spray that product
because joe said it wasn't working and
so that that's where we've run into a
lot of problems or people say yeah put
it out and it's anything so I went ahead
one week later and put another dose out
you know though that's another and then
you get rapid activity anyway so one
year out the second year is when you
assess where where are we did we get
where we want to be do we need to change
things up okay it's just like it's about
seeding as well let's just let's these
two other things that are critical when
this thing was coming up and
looked like a registration was imminent
there was a note that went out to the
folks that were tested in and I was
privy to it then hey you can't do this
near drainlines now I don't need to get
into the politics of this but I would
hold it up in New York and worse yet if
it has water quality or water movement
stuff it's a no sale on Long Island and
I hate to say that to my Long Island
friends yeah a little bit about that I'm
with you Long Island friends if it had
issues I wouldn't recommend it and so it
wasn't really a political thing that
happened what happened was it was kind
of a speed of flow through issue with
EPA they originally the company had
submitted all the documentation for
aquatic toxicity they asked for and
received a waiver from the EPA that
allowed them to use agent route instead
of rainbow trout which is normally what
they require okay they already had data
on Asian trout which was exactly what
the EPA wanted but they didn't have it
on rainbow trout EPA said sure
give CAG trial they got the Asian trout
data and right before the eup the
experimental use permit program that
you're talking about where the drain
tile issue came up right before that
happened one of the EPA scientists just
wasn't happy about it was a no effect
level but he wasn't happy about one of
those Asian trial levels so they
essentially midstream changed their mind
and said we don't want agent trout
anymore we want you to do the rainbow
trout that is in our documentation so
they kind of reneged on you know they
basically rejected the REC the Asian
trout data they wanted to study redone
with rainbow trout so then two things
happen the first was the company had to
then do I don't know a million-dollar
rainbow trout study and that takes time
that was one of those delays the other
is EPA suddenly puts the product in a
category okay we don't have any aquatic
oxidative so since we don't have any
data if we add data but you know I'm
saying it didn't qualify now because the
guys said I don't want it so they placed
it in a category of
you know we gotta air on the safety and
so they put that restriction on the EP
now that the SC formulation is
registered in the United States here's
your proof that it's not a problem no
drain tile restriction in fact the only
stipulation regarding water is that you
cannot spray the product directly into
the water so an island green is good to
go you can spray right there is no
buffer zone you can spray right to
within an inch of water as long as you
know that you're not spraying on the
water so well I just I'll give you a yes
you know making it through California in
New York that's gonna be the acid test
and especially Long Island which is much
like California one last thing see if
there's any questions you know six
applications you know I want to keep it
out I get a little nervous it might be
coming back in should I keep using that
thes ole in am I worried about
developing resistance that's of course
as a weed scientist comes to my mind but
also can I transition to a trim it
program can I transition to a tenacity
well not with Bank grasses but some
places what do you recommend number one
about resistance management about and -
I'm assuming other products are going to
be part and parcel to that absolutely
and from a resistance management
standpoint on the one hand as you say we
are we're placing ourselves in in a
scenario that is ripe for developing
resistance because to ensure bit grass
playability we are trying to down the
rate back and meat or the product out at
these low sub-lethal rates until finally
we get the mortality we desert that we
want and that mortality is coming from a
combination not just of the herbicide
which the herbicide could do it but
we're we're using herbicide Plus bit
competition to get that job an
environmental stress to get that job
done and so we're trying to do is slowly
as possible we're setting ourselves up
to the belt resistance right but on the
other hand we have a system that is much
much less capable of developing
resistance and the reason I
say that is we have a product that's
going to be priced such that it's going
to be targeted applications only primary
greens otherwise targeted to collars or
localized areas so we're not going to be
bringing resistant seed from elsewhere
on the Golf Course onto greens right the
resistance problem if it's going to
develop it's going to develop on the
grain and you better damn well be
managing it on the grid like if you see
once you go through a renovation program
which I would say should take you should
be two years out before you consider to
put the rubber stamp on that and say
we're done
at that point you should be managing any
escape hole with a pocketknife you
should be managing with with a dabber
you know we've done work with divers
using paccarb uses all which is a pretty
cool option to limit green stress
dabbers with ochre so that you can you
know save some money and isolate the
product only where you want it those are
really good options to manage resistance
so we're on these little isolated
islands where the product is applied and
we don't have to worry about nasty stuff
coming in from the outside and that's
the big difference it's going to keep
resistance from becoming an issue on
everything but you know what it it does
sound like it's on your mind though I
I'm with you a hundred percent you know
we get this really good tool we've had
really good tools this is human behavior
where if we don't steward it properly if
we don't manage our P's and Q's in the
way we're using it we're going to lose
it and no matter what companies tell us
we you know listen
money is only gonna stop a certain layer
of this industry there's some parts of
this industry that money is not going to
stop them are you more concerned if we
go to teas and fairways and approaches
well so we've got we've got another
thing that's helping us out besides site
specificity in the application we have
an alternate mode of action and it's
called turf grass competition yeah the
resistance development inter is not not
completely but mostly limited to dormant
turf situation
she's like poor Angela oh the entire
southern United States is resistant to
triazines and schedule SS DNA's because
they're targeting polar in a period when
they don't have that alternate mode of
action when they don't have that turf
competition that's right in the North
we're pretty much always going to have
turf competition to help manage that in
Korea they've been using the product for
pretty much a decade now no cases of
resistance they've been using it now in
Japan for a year or a little over a year
so no cases of resistance so far in
practice yeah we're always worried and
it's you know it's it's funny too it's
it's funny because listen we associate
resistance we go we'll do a little deep
dive here know if there's questions Carl
but I got a weed scientist so I'm not
going to yeah in my head in my mind I'm
thinking if we don't even know the mode
of action you can't seem to isolate cell
wall or the t-80 mode of action is it
possible it's multi-site in a way that
we're not familiar with even testing
it's very well I'll tell you everybody
talks about these herbicides like this
one's an ALS inhibitor and that one is a
photosystem inhibitor [ __ ] but so
each herbicide is going to have well
potentially can have don't let me
overstep my bounds I'm not a
physiologist but these herbicides can
have a different mechanism of acting on
one species than they do in another
Quinn cleric is an excellent example now
that is not killing crabgrass via you
know hormone induced aux-in mimic
mimicry
you know it's killing crabgrass by being
a cell wall biosynthesis inhibitor so
here we have a product that kills clover
as an oxen mimic and crabgrass as a CB I
hope you're in our lab we we have pretty
much proven that there is a very low
level a very low level t-80 inhibition
going on or at least something that
causes bleaching symptoms and can be
very partially mitigated by
adding back hoe magenta see acid so we
agree with the the German lab in that
respect that the t-80 inhibition is
happening but what we were able to show
that unlike what they concluded ta T's
not killing polar it's definitely not
killing poem and it's definitely not
even a major player like I don't think
it is the the element that's responsible
for killing anything we repeated all of
the studies that have been done and we
found that the results that they showed
were kind of exaggerated we saw some of
the same stuff but nowhere near at the
magnitude and then when we looked at it
on poorer
it was non-existent on polar whereas on
duck weed it was so but we know it does
act on ta t I've seen actual bleached
plants in the field like broadleaf
plants and things like that's rare but
the true mechanism of killing poor dr.
Koo SJ ku the CEO of the company he
believes that it's probably a mechanism
that's related to the grameen aside it's
kind of like the ACC ace inhibitors
either a lipid biosynthesis inhibition
or a fatty acid because you know I mean
it has this odd selectivity that is
another way to get at this now listen we
could talk about this forever Carl are
there questions yeah one from John and I
know Shaun was touching on earlier about
maybe some abiotic factors that could
come into play John's wonder if there's
any concerns high heat days if you're
applying it then in March I know it kind
of maybe you'll get a random 90 degree
days something like that anything to be
concerned with there well so the thing
to be concerned about is stress and and
in particular stress that can lead to
root senescence in poem so what we have
seen is aeration for example if you put
pala cure out in conjunction with an era
fication and topdressing event we pretty
much every time see much more rapid Poe
in your control and on occasion we've
seen been injury some mild fight oh we
actually had one series of studies that
we repeated and saw consistently if you
do this if you have a stressful era
fication
Plus at the farm there is something
going on with the ethylene escalation
that's happening from Epiphone and
ethylene acts as a hormone I believe and
it's shown to promote senescence
ripening etc and other I believe that
ethylene escalation from the f-fine is
causing that environmentally do induced
root senescence to go nuts and we're
losing you know where normally we would
lose 30% of the roots we might be losing
80% of the roots well they have to come
back from the crown if pol cure is on
the ground and you're in the middle of a
repeated application Spring Park your
program and you lose eighty percent of
your roots if it weren't for the pol
cured one week later no big deal roots
would be back down but if you've got a
band of four cure right there and the
roots have to come back from the crown
50 60 70 percent of them at least while
the fourth your concentrations high and
if they're not coming back well it will
lose bit grass or you're going to be
able to go out and pull a plug and say
whoa on the pole cure treated side I got
like almost no roots and over here where
I didn't treat poor cure it's already
back down to ten inches and so it's you
have to you have to manage stress as
best as you can while you're in the
middle of a pork your program so you
know either get your Arif occation like
if you're Corey refine I get that healed
in before you start you always want to
be two weeks apart from any other
potentially stressful application like a
packer butas on or for criminal like an
era fication chin two weeks before or
after and you want your pork to your
program in the middle there so so listen
if one of the things we see a lot of
people doing and there certainly are
places where this could happen as a
result of the pandemic and maybe some
right sizing people may decide hey maybe
we're gonna have Bank grass greens now
if I start out with a really good Bank
grass green when do or do I ever
consider a poker program would I just do
dotting would I go to a PGR program and
I'm thinking about those people that
might have put Bank rats in recently or
the last five years
some PO is coming in what about for
approach
get where you've got a lot of good
competition that's a great question and
you know there's a lot of people are
gonna fit that mold because they're
gonna one thing poor cure can't do for
you they can't update your bentgrass
variety right right and so people are
going to take that advantage of say okay
now I can keep it clean let's do it all
right so you can get on so the the poker
is being as far as I know they're
marketing it there's two strategies
there's the renovation strategy which is
getting rid of the old Pola that you
have and while keeping the vent you have
and growing it back in and then there is
a maintenance program the maintenance
program is two apps a year it's going to
cost for the year less than a PG our
program would ruin your life if you're
going out with trim it on a routine
program and that's cost can you say
thirty five hundred a year that's about
what your maintenance program for pork
here to keep polar from coming into
those new greens would would call
somewhere in there and I'm pretty sure
what they're going to promote is kind of
a strategy where you rotate between you
know PGR or you could if you want to do
both if you've got the budget you can
come in with that single spring app of
Poker 0.6 fluid ounce and then two weeks
later at least you get on whatever
you're if you're doing Cutlass if you're
doing trimming or one of those type of
programs you're going to get on that and
stay on that to make sure that anything
mid summer can't come back and then in
the fall you're going to hit it again
with coal cure so that program is meant
to keep a long-term residual of Mathias
oh and in the sole so that you pull off
seeding seedlings that are brought in by
cleats and and God knows what else
watershed over the green can't you know
get hope or so so that that program is
part of it but again always keep that
resistance in the back of your mind and
always try to come up with your own
strategy to rotate other strategies into
that program that's right it's good to
hear it's been in Korea for a decade and
they're not talking about resistance
problems Carl we're well past you know
if you don't say something I'm just
gonna keep talking so are there other
questions or we're gonna thank Sean and
get him on with his day no more
questions I think that was a really good
summary of this though and then
obviously we'll throw this up on a
recording I know a lot of people are out
it's a tea time in New York
Haymitch country songs you got one for
polo cure you haven't heard any of my
rap or a rock stuff you know come on man
no I just figured with it with with
where you are and how you sound here
you're built for the country music thing
send me a link will make will promote
you in commuter song you rapping you rap
look I'll send you one okay Sean thank
you so much - what a pleasure seeing you
thanks a lot everybody for joining us we
we don't know when we'll see you again
so thanks for taking the time hopefully
this was a little bit of a respite for
everybody during a really difficult time
we're so lucky to have great colleagues
like Sean and a partner like Carl can
put up with me for these times thanks
very much everybody
everybody this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu